hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 1
video I hope you guys like the episode
it's kind of like a whole new direction
for this show it's almost like they did
a completely new pilot like it's not
even recognizable compared to a season 1
maybe you know even season 2 season 2 is
a big step up from season 1 but this is
way way better the name of the game of
the season is all about the Inhumans and
I'll talk a little bit about some of the
surprise twists in the episode after we
get to spoilers but essentially they're
just weaving more and more stuff from
the movies into this now obviously it's
the first episode it's the premiere so
they're gonna roll heavy on integration
stuff I'm not expecting movie references
of this level every single week but the
ones that they did make were a lot more
meaningful I feel like than the ones
they made in season 2 so just careful
for spoilers as we get into it I'm gonna
start with top 5 moments and I'll try to
explain who some of the new comic book
characters they introduced are starting
with number 5 these new fish oil pills
are totally the bomb if you miss the
Infinity arc from the comics from a
couple years ago it was a while ago at
this point Black Bolt sets off a
Terrigen bomb in New York City that
creates a whole bunch of new Inhumans
that was the event that created the
Kamala Khan Miss Marvel that led to a
reboot of the Inhumans comic book and as
part of that lash was created the big
freaky blue guy with the lightsaber
hands that we met in this episode the
other new character Joey is not from the
comic books he's an original creation of
the show as is constant Zimmer this
character here who's kind of like the
face of the governmental antagonist
there are a couple of different kinds of
bad guys walking around some that are
evil some with misguided intentions and
some who feel like they're burdened with
glorious purpose Loki would be proud the
way they explain the fish oil pills as
as expected is that the diviner material
that was actually like turning people to
stone and ash like the people who didn't
have inhuman DNA that got filtered out
so if you're not an inhuman and you take
the fish oil pills you'll be fine but
like this right here enjoy his apartment
in the beginning that's his cocoon
remember Skye and Raina went into
cocoons when they went through
terrigenesis so this year isn't like the
remains of a human it's just the cocoon
that joy was in as a device I totally
buy the fish oil pills it just allows
the show's writers to control the number
of Inhumans that pop up because if there
were a bomb like an actual bomb there'd
be thousands of them all at once as
Coulson explained Joey is the first one
that they've been able to help in recent
memory they've lost
five before that five that this Rosalind
character that's actually what constants
inverse names supposed to be five that
roselyn's group has gotten and it looks
like they're dissecting them and trying
to study them so even if she has the
best of intentions technically she's one
of the villains right now moving out to
number four meet the face of Civil War
Constance Zimmer aka Rosalind not a
comic book character but she did
reference some things that were
relatively close to the comics she talks
about space exploration in the DoD not
eating at separate tables anymore that's
kind of like a sword reference they're
kind of like a space-based version of
shield in the comics but it's still like
an earth organization based on earth the
way they're presenting her makes me feel
like she's part of some new government
initiative that we're gonna see during
civil war like some group that's super
powerful just like shield was operates
with a certain amount of autonomy and
has influence over the president because
the president who's actually the same
president from Iron Man 3 by the way
mirrors the same line that she said on
the subway about the laws of God man
just to take a trip down memory lane
Iron Man 3 was all about aim trying to
take over with its extremist technology
but it's nice that they got the same
actor from that movie to play the
president in this because there's so
much government stuff going on in civil
war I wouldn't be surprised if he also
shows up in Captain America Civil War
but after seeing Coulson and Rosalind
scenes I just totally want to show with
just the two of them I totally ship it
Aaron Sorkin's cagey banter coming fall
2016 the funny thing is that Clark Gregg
was actually a character on Aaron
Sorkin's West Wing he was like an FBI
agent so he was like a Coulson character
on an Aaron Sorkin's show already the
speaking of loss on to number three meet
lash one of the big new comic book
characters this season and literally big
to not just figuratively like I said he
was born out of the new Inhumans
storyline pre Secret Wars so I mean
giving his continuity is kind of in flux
right now they might change him a little
bit afterwards but he views all these
new Inhumans popping up after the the
Terrigen bomb goes off or the fish oil
pills if you're talking about the TV
show as an affront to the Inhumans way
of life they have a very strict
tradition and code for living so he
takes it on himself to clear the world
all these new Inhumans the question is
is if he's taking orders from someone
else or if he's operating by himself
I'm really hoping they roll some bigger
inhuman character out that he's working
but just explain the way his powers work
he has energy conversion abilities where
he can take energy from other sources
convert it and redirect it through his
hands so that's why it looks like he has
lightsaber hands when he cuts through
the wall
so you see Lincoln shooting him with his
energy projectiles lash can absorb that
and redirect it so they kind of cancel
each other out a little bit on the
number two
Fitz is losing his trying to find a
way to save Jemma from that obelisk this
is his character doing a complete 180
from last year and I could not be
happier he is so much more badass right
now I'm gonna get a lot of mileage out
of the jiff of him pounding on that
obelisk when he's talking to Coulson we
also get a whole bunch of exposition we
get some name drops for Pym technologies
more offhanded movie references we also
find out that Coulson is on his third
hand which i think is pretty cool all I
can think about is Luke Skywalker's hand
I think eventually he'll get a vibranium
hand nothing feels right so far and
they're actually keeping his old stone
hand in a case which i think is kind of
creepy and cool at the same time and
finally onto my number one WTF moment
Simmons shows up on the other side of
the universe and it turns out the
obelisk actually just transported her
through space-time that was one of the
things that Fitz was talking about he
said he said that the obelisk was
capable of warping space-time so it
acted kind of like a gateway but it
seems like it has a certain level of
intelligence so it probably brought
Simmons to that place for a special
reason
but when we see her it looks like she's
trying to escape from someone like she's
running she's been there a while she
marks her forehead as if she's been
there for a while and she's learned
something about the people that are
trying to track her down now what I
think is going on because this is a Kree
obelisk it probably just sucked her to
another create post she'll probably be a
conduit for us learning more about the
in human society in their background not
expecting any kind of royal family
members to show up like Black Bolt or
Medusa or anything like that but we will
plug it to see some more Inhumans creel
or now as for a clan I think that that's
still hidden on earth we probably won't
see that till the Inhumans movie shows
up but don't be surprised if you hear
tons of guardians of the galaxy royal
family related things going on during
Simmons storylines and it seems like
she's probably not going to make it back
anytime soon like they just teased her
so obviously we got to follow up next
week and find out what's going on then
her crucible here like on this other
planet has to run its course just in
general though this episode definite a
plus in terms of premieres just a
dramatic 180 from where the shows been
so far it was a lot of fun last year but
I feel like now it's actually like
really really good so if you know
anybody or you have any friends that
quit the show after season one tell them
to start watching again now let me know
in the comments though what are you most
excited to find out like what is the
biggest mystery for you on the show
right now I feel like most of us are
wondering what's going on with Simmons
the rest of the episode is pretty
straightforward like bobbi and Hunter
gonna go after Ward at a certain point
may is floating around she's probably
gonna go after Ward to on her own that's
probably why she hasn't come back yet
roselyn's group is just gonna
precipitate what's gonna be going on in
civil war with the government trying to
track down bag and tag these Inhumans
most of the movie references were just
like the biggest WTS from some of the
movies like sokovia dropping from the
sky Coulson being dead before shield
died which is you know way back to
Winter Soldier in the first Avengers
films some of you were commenting that
you heard some Doctor Strange Easter
eggs I didn't hear any but I mean I was
taking notes while I was watching the
episode so I'm gonna have to watch it
again to double-check but generally you
know most of the references were to
movies that have already happened I know
a lot of you want to know when that
Civil War trailers gonna drop it's
probably gonna be coming in the next
couple of weeks I think there's actually
a new Batman V Superman trailer that's
gonna be dropping soon too I know there
was a lot of guardians of the galaxy
imagery especially at the end of the
episode James Gunn is getting ready to
shoot guardians to really soon they're
actually shooting out of Atlanta so
before too long there's gonna be a lot
of news coming from that movie from the
set like we already kind of got that
with Civil War they're pretty much done
shooting Civil War but they're just
ramping up on guardians too so you guys
get excited about that there's gonna be
so much more oval stuff
Jessica Jones actually if you don't know
about that TV series that's airing at
the end of November it's all dropping on
Netflix all at the same time and yes
I'll totally be doing videos for it so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
if there's any bonus Marvel's Inhumans
videos that you guys want me to do in
the meantime just let me know in the
comments so while you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here
for the latest trailer from the flash
season 2 just teasing a bunch of
firestorm zoom stuff and you can click
here to learn all about Marvel's
Inhumans in the comics thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you